[Music]
net thank you so much for joining me I
am so um excited to be inspired by you H
in in our next uh session here where um
the the work you've done um is is really
remarkable I just shared with you a
second ago how remarkable I think it is
because I I truly believe that H and and
I think it's very entrepreneurial I
think it's high impact and I think it
really speaks to the the nature of this
Unity of United Nation coming together
and every person pulling their weight
but you're actually acting as a platform
for that so I'm especially excited about
Platforms in the startup ecosystem and
now you're bringing this platform play
also to uh this this uh this uh United
um effort so thank you again for for
agreeing to be here I know how busy you
are um tell me a little bit about
yourself in general who are you Neta
what are you doing today today I'm Neta
I'm a co-founder and uh CEO of Vault
platform vault is the all-in-one digital
platform for employee reporting
corporate investigations and data
analytics which enables employees to
speak up in ways that feel comfortable
and confident for them to do so and to
raise any ethical breaches ESG
violations of uh any kind uh misconduct
um a lot of corruption uh and uh and uh
fraud are being reported through our
platform and it enables um uh companies
to identify repeated patterns historical
patterns and to investigate these cases
effectively and immediately through
means that just weren't available to
them uh uh prior and uh finally to
understand the health of their business
from an ethical standpoint and uh
Viewpoint so yeah that's all beautiful
we we all see how you know how how much
respect and attention has been given to
human resources and employee engagement
and employee retention over the last at
least I think several years so obviously
the ability to provide a platform for
them to speak up and and to get them to
engage with these considerations was
remarkable before we get into the War I
I was just at an event with the co of
cloud Flair and he mentioned how he
spent so much of his time working on
engaging with employees to get them to
trust him so that they report to him
when they see something going wrong
because he realizes that is the number
one H big big thing that's on his plate
as a large Enterprise not going to talk
about that anymore I want to talk about
October 7th because and we'll talk about
that in a separate cont context you
you've done really meaningful work there
where where were you on October 7th 6:30
a.m. yeah so October 6th I landed in
Israel um which is where I'm based for
the last two years so started the
company out of London and um moved to
Israel about two years ago um October
6th I landed from Chicago from a large
conference um for my industry October
7th in the morning 6:30 in the morning
um my girls woke me up that there is a a
funny sound outside that they that they
don't recognize my daughters unlike many
Israeli children are not accustomed to
the sound of sirens cuz they grew up in
London um and I you know feeling very
jetlagged and not really sure you know
what time of the day it is I I paid no
attention I thought I I I didn't even
realize what I'm hearing myself but then
um within an hour there was or maybe
even less there was an additional um
additional uh siren additional alarm and
um this time when they jumped on my bed
I realized what's happening I was in my
pajamas and I just
shouted down down to the shelter now
let's go and they didn't understand what
I'm talking about I grabbed my keys
grabbed my phone went down to the
shelter and that was our first
experience as an Israeli family uh
through uh through those Sirens um
starting to kind of realizing what I'm
hearing what's happening the Third the
third one went went off within an
additional hour and uh uh with the news
kind of started to you know uh come from
all over it felt ve very quickly we
understood that um whilst the the
country's attention or you know Tel av's
attention was given to the um to the
rocket attack um actually uh um
something far more grave and terrible is
happening down south and um piece by
piece minute by minute we realized um
just how terrible it is but of course
the the the true scale of This Disaster
wasn't wasn't clear until much later
that day of course and and actually also
in the unfolding of the next couple of
days I think we've we've all came to
understand what what really is happening
and this is not and it's far beyond what
what we've experienced definitely Our
Generation Um it's it's way too similar
to that of previous generations
unfortunately um and so um you know
every person thinks to themselves what
they're going to do and how they're
going to react you you're running a
company H but what you've been doing
over the last few weeks besides running
a company has also been um coming
together and in an effort to to be
significant part of of the of the war so
tell me a little bit about what how what
how how stand with Israel and how tech
for tech for Israel unfolded all these
few weeks so first of all I would say it
wasn't side by side with running a
company it was completely instead um I
wow I'm now coming back to work but it's
been two weeks that I and I need to be
very thankful to my London based team
that just um I could completely delegate
and and rely very heavily on my people
and on my team wow to just uh hold the
fort because it was clear that um I mean
of course yes there was the volunteering
there was these these projects but the
the grief and the shock were um
completely crippling in ways that I
haven't experienced and you know um as a
founder I went through coid I went
through a lot of things I let Financial
downturn I went through svb um you know
crashing down I think you know I had my
share of Crisis this was something like
on a on a whole other scale that just
completely paralyzed me um I have to say
um but this actual this feeling of um
vulnerability and helplessness is really
something that drove me and so many
others to action I think this is how
this is how we deal with it right like
at the when we feel so helpless um all
we can think about is how we help and
what do we do and how we um Channel our
energies and the things we're good at
and our into into action and so that's
what we started to see really very much
on scale um with the Tech Community in
Israel I was already part of many groups
that were very well organized even
before the war because we had you know
we had the um the the the protest groups
uh uh against the the judicial uh
overhaul so there was a lot of already
infrastructure there there were there
were you know there was a there were
communities that were already created
working and knowing how to work together
with people you never met you don't know
but you're working together towards a
cause and that Spirit was very much
already there ready for us to kind of
embark on so what we've done is we've
completely
diverted um the you know uh tech tech
for democracy which was you know the the
names of the the the prior name of our
of our community uh which includes about
um 500 heads of companies uh across all
stages in Israeli Tech and we've just
completely channeled it into action um
and within days all these initiatives
exploded and um the things that were put
forward were pretty incredible so um I
decided to focus my my time on uh you
know well we all need to know I'm sure
you know Michael how to how to fund
raise we all need to have that basic
skill in order to be where we're where
we're at um kind of Channel those skills
and to and learn about the world of
donations because we understood that
what we need right now is to just
mobilize large amounts have you raised
the donations before before this no so
I'm pretty new to the world of
philanthropy um and I had to learn
really really quickly but um not anymore
now that not anymore I really I know I
know a lot about how you know how to get
a a tax deductible donation and out of
the US today which is definitely not
something or you know and you very
little about the third sector or the
charity world at all but it was just
really really clear that what we need to
do right now at the scale of what we're
facing is just to just to ensure that
Capital keeps flowing into where it's
needed most um and in real time so um
quick you know I don't I don't even know
how it happened I just I just started
running with I got I got phone calls
from people I know from wealthy
individuals in the US asking me you know
how can I help how can I help I want to
write a check where does it go I I don't
I don't know I don't know where uh I
don't know how you can do this and then
going back into my community um we start
organizing ourselves around these
initiatives um I need to say a big you
know just to kind of hats off to
companies like Wix and Munday and and
and and and many others large um Israeli
companies who made all their talent
available uh everyone were just free to
work on any volunteering initiative that
they want for a good amount of time and
so we got together groups of people
teams that never worked together before
to solve a problem and to solve it
quickly and that's how that's how it all
came about and incredible incredible
okay so took leadership obviously you're
you're a leader by nature and that's
what you do you you said before a
sentence something like you know when
when shitthe heads the fan or you didn't
use those that phrase I'm that's my
phrase and you know people people come
together and they do what they can to
help that's not always the case not not
everywhere in the world this is a
special case where it it is happening
and you're you're you're an example of
of that and and I'm very A coping
mechanism that's that's all it is I
really think that's a coping mechanism
with
perhaps and and I think it's more than
that I think that there's a I think that
in light in in light of you mentioned
that you trans you took groups that were
already organized for the protest and
then for those that are unaware because
we have an international audience here
we had obviously political turmoil for
the months leading up to this to this uh
Massacre and this war and effectively
the the whole the the dissonance is that
the the groups that you're talking about
they were formed in part of a of a big
big crisis internally a with with a
fragmentation within the Israeli society
and all of a sudden you're transitioning
that same group into into a pro
something that the entire nation is
coming together with and I think that's
beautiful but but going back to the D
nation and tell me a little bit about
the platform that you've built the
solution you've built how the team
formed and what is the impact that this
has had over just the last I guess 15
days or so it's been it's just been two
weeks so what's been happening with this
with stand with Israel right so stand
with Israel was kind of one initiative
leading into another St with Israel is
something I'm uh really really proud of
uh started this with uh uh a wonderful
guy called Amit sabag and an amazing
team of volunteers out of Wix um and so
we started this platform which uh
enables donations to all the listed
Israeli foundations that uh are open to
donations from abroad so it's an
aggregator website that Aggregates all
those charitable foundations including
Israel's biggest hospitals um including
uh um the biggest NOS anyone who is
active and has an active role in the in
the in the war in providing Aid and
support and relief it enables uh any
donor to choose a cause that is close to
their heart and there are much smaller
foundations there as well we're seeing a
lot of money flowing into mental health
right now obviously the um the the
mental trauma that many Israelis are
experiencing is uh is immense and um
PTSD will become a huge issue
unfortunately in our country for
children and adults alike and so 100%
And so it really enables people to
choose kind of the the uh a a cause of
choice and uh and to enable uh
charitable foundations one of the
amazing things we've done here
especially for the US audience for the
US donors is we connected Sten with
Israel uh with a an infrastructure that
allows people very quickly to donate
through their donor advisor funds uh and
for that I need to just also uh uh give
a big shout out to Chariot uh a startup
that a USB startup that we started
working with that enables donors to
choose a foundation and with two clicks
just release money out of their donor
advisor fund directly um into the into
the foundation of choice so um we know
that already
um the the overall um sums that were
collected through our platform um are uh
millions of dollars already kind of
flowing um directly into those
foundations uh actually we believe
actually we're closer to tens of
millions at this point um and um and uh
we're we're just making it easy uh as
much as possible for people to donate
where where they want to uh and to whom
they want to so that's that was the
first initiative the second initiative
um is more uh is called tech for Israel
uh website being Tech uh for number4
israel.com
and uh this is a special initiative that
we started with um leading figures in
Israeli Tech so we have few very
prominent CEOs and VCS in this uh in
this initiative and essentially what it
is it also is also a Channel or a
vehicle uh for outside donations to come
into Israel we're focusing on large
donations on behalf of other foundations
family offices heed worth
individuals um and companies and um what
we're doing here is we have sight we
have visibility over ad hoc realtime
needs as they evolve and as they come to
us on a daily basis needs that sometimes
cannot be met by the large foundations
cannot be met by the large nonprofits um
give me give me a couple of examples
just to water the ear we need uh to find
a 100 mattresses for members of one of
the kutas that were evacuated down in
the South uh so that um you know so that
we can uh uh house them we need uh uh to
send uh uh to sponsor Psychological
Services to Children um in one of the
hotels where another kibuts is being and
the reason why they can't go to the
large or to the large um nonprofits is
because so look the nonprofits are doing
amazing work yeah don't get me wrong but
they have a mandate uh of what it is
they can and cannot sponsor they have a
process they have their own agenda and
they do their work now I want to be very
very clear I think it's amazing that
these NOS these foundations these
hospitals have now got really incredible
amount of uh charitable donations that
will allow them to rebuild themselves
for the long term and that's incredible
what a tech for Israel were focused on
is the needs of today how can we meet
the needs of today and of tomorrow uh in
order to provide relief that is
immediate our um we already have a
slogan and that is um a immediate impact
zero overhead so this there you know
there are no salaries being paid there's
no overhead at all um it we are a very
quick direct channel uh from donor to
impact at no time that's basically what
we want to what we want to
enable beautiful can you share with me a
little bit about the volume what is some
examples of what's been happening over
the last two weeks then with the context
two weeks you know where theend this is
going to be published it'll be I guess 3
weeks and so things will change but you
know today October 23rd where are we at
yeah so um Millions were already donated
s singlehandedly through this platform
um it is currently uh we haven't gone
very wide with it we we we we you know
we will um at this point uh we opened it
up Millions that's a lot it's a lot um
of dollars um at this point we opened it
to our networks and to so again the
biggest funds in Israel um and some of
the most prominent CEOs are there um we
can talk about specific names but uh
names that everyone owes are like the
you know the the the shining stars of of
the Israeli Tech ecosystem at the end of
the day the idea is that through these
networks um knowing you know who stands
behind this fund um we are all
channeling our energies right now in
order to uh to just again to just offer
as much relief as possible uh and and I
think that why why this project I think
is so important especially in the
context of this series is that it's it's
not not only are you on a personal level
exemplifying the the the idea of coming
together stopping what we're doing
United effort in this context for for
everybody but but also your your your
platform that's what it does right your
your platform enables the unification of
people around the world particularly
around it sounds like the US and connect
them to have them also be able to give
their own effort so you're so so I think
that it's it's a double um you know it's
it's it's a double layer of what we're
trying to do yeah um and so and that's
amazing thank you for for doing this uh
well um it it feels like a like a little
drop in the sea um again I think we're
all just doing what we what we can um
and and the you know the next the next
Frontier is uh is to get the world's
attention um and um and to ensure that
we have the support that we need to win
this because there's no there's no other
way there's no other way uh there's just
no other way and that's uh 100% um Neta
I I want to thank you I I really want to
think this was a phenomenal inspiring um
and again I think that's it's truly an
an example of of a shining example of
exact PB the the mentality that that I
want to capture and in what's happening
here and what what has been so inspiring
for me in my own efforts and the efforts
that I've been
ex observing around so thank you very
very much continue making a positive
impact um I'm still a you know you be
glossed over it but the fact that you
you you technically you said you you
delegated and you were able to to focus
on this solely for two weeks I know as a
CEO what that means for a startup and
that's not trivial and that's um and and
I think it also speaks to to though how
how probably your qualities as a CEO
were that you were able to do that I
speak to the qualities of my team and I
think and that's you know and that is
something I'm incredibly proud of but U
just back to your point about Unity I
think what our society has
demonstrated um in in the last two weeks
um and how we yet again um rise from the
rebels um and we do that um as one
people I think we've we've shown again
um how powerful we can
[Laughter]
be
[Music]